before we get to the issues let's
address the elephant not in the room
tonight Donald Trump has chosen not to
attend this evenings presidential debate
what message do you think that sends to
the voters of Iowa when you treat it
badly you have to stick up for your wife
to have to do it and everyone on this
stage is stupid fat and ugly and then
you're a terrible surgeon now that we've
gotten the Donald Trump portion out of
the way Donald Trump for example I'm
glad he'd mentioned his name again just
anybody was missing him mr. Trump
believed that in reaction to people's
fears that we should ban all Muslims
well that creates an environment that's
toxic in our own country